LET'S LISTEN IN HERE.
THE KING AND THE QUEEN CONSORT
HAVE LEFT THE LIMO TO GREET SOME
OF THE CROWDS, AN ENORMOUS CROWD
OUTSIDE BUCKINGHAM PALACE HERE.
THIS IS QUITE A MOMENT.
WE WERE DISCUSSING EARLIER THE
KING MAKING HIS FIRST COMMENTS
TO THE NATION, GREETING THE
NATION AS THE NEW MONARCH.
HERE HE IS DOING IT FACE TO
FACE, HAND TO HAND.
>> LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO
LISTEN.
>> SO SORRY ABOUT YOUR MUM.
>> LONG LIVE THE KING!
>> GOD SAVE THE KING!
>> ENJOY THE MOMENT.
>> WE WISH YOU SUCCESS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, CHARLES.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO BE A
FANTASTIC KING.
>> LONG LIVE THE KING!
>> GOD SAVE THE KING!
>> THANK YOU
.
>> GOD SAVE THE KING!
GOD SAVE THE KING!
>> SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS, SIR.
>> WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> PHONES DOWN, PLEASE, LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN.
>> PHONE DOWN, SIR.
♪ GOD SAVE
THY GRACIOUS KING ♪
>> THANK YOU, CHARLES!
>> WE LOVE YOU, KING CHARLES!
WE LOVE YOU A LOT!
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> SO SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS.
>> GOD SAVE THE KING!
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> REMARKABLE TO SEE THIS, TO
HEAR THE SINGING BREAKING OUT,
FOR A MOMENT.
>> I DO THINK THEY WERE STILL
SINGING GOD SAVE THE QIUEEN?
>> YOU MAY BE RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE LIVE
PICTURES UP.
WHAT A MOMENT TO SEE IN LONDON.
BEAUTIFUL BLUE SUNNY SKIES ON
THIS DAY WHERE KING CHARLES IS
GREETING SO MANY PEOPLE THERE.
LET'S BRING IN OUR COLLEAGUES
AND FRIENDS, MAX FOSTER, DON
LEMON.
YOU GUYS ARE THERE.
WHAT'S IT LIKE?
>> YEAH, WELL, I GOT TO TELL
YOU, I HAVE FIVE MINUTES, FIVE
MINUTES AWAY IN THE CROWD AFTER
DOING "NEW DAY," THE MORNING
SHOW.
AND I HEARD THE ROAR AND GOT
CALLED BACK AND THERE ARE JUST
THRONGS OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SHOWED UP AND JUST IN THE COUPLE
MOMENTS SINCE WE HAVE BEEN HERE
FOR -- DURING THIS SHOW.
AND IT IS INTERESTING BECAUSE
YOU'RE RIGHT, JIM, YOU DID HEAR
GOD SAVE THE KING.
AND IT IS JUST -- MAX TOLD ME
EARLIER THAT HE MAY COME THE NEW
KING TO LOOK AT THE FLOWERS, BUT
HE HAS COME TO GREET THE PEOPLE.
AND THEY ARE EXCITED TO SEE
THEIR NEW KING AT THE SAME TIME,
MOURNING THE LOSS OF THE FORMER
QUEEN, HIS MOTHER.
SO THIS IS QUITE A MOMENT TO
WITNESS, MAX, DON'T YOU AGREE?
>> GOT A KISS ON THE LIPS.
I THINK THIS WILL BE VERY
HEARTENING TO HIM TO -- YOU
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU WILL BE
ACCEPTED INTO THE TOP JOB UNTIL
YOU'RE THERE AND THE COMING OUT
AND THEY'RE SAYING GOD SAVE THE
KING, SINGING THE NATIONAL
ANTHEM WITH KING IN THE NATIONAL
ANTHEM.
AND THEY ARE THRILLED TO SEE
HIM, THIS IS REALLY POSITIVE.
HE IS A SENSITIVE SOUL, PRINCE
CHARLES.
HE'S QUITE SENSITIVE AND THIS
WILL BE HUGE FOR HIM.
BUT JUST TO PUT THIS INTO
CONTEXT, THIS IS KING CHARLES
II, MEETING HIS SUBJECTS, FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
SO THIS IS HISTORIC.
>> AND MEETING HIS SUBJECTS AT A
TIME WHEN AT THE SAME TIME HE
LOST HIS MOTHER, JUST A COUPLE
OF DAYS AGO, AND NOW HAVING, YOU
KNOW, HIS ENTIRE FAMILY TO BE
BROUGHT BACK IN AND TO BE
BROUGHT BACK IN NOT FOR HIM, YOU
KNOW, GAINING THE CROWN OR
BECOMING KING, BUT REALLY FOR
THE LOSS OF HIS MOTHER.
SO THERE WAS SOME, I DON'T KNOW
I SHOULD SAY CONCERN, BUT PEOPLE
WONDERING HOW WOULD HE BE
ACCEPTED?
HOW IS HE GOING TO REIGN?
AND IT APPEARS NOW THAT PEOPLE
ARE OPEN TO HIM.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE RECEPTION OF
THIS CROWD, THAT SEEMS TO BE THE
CASE.
>> CHARLES II, CHARLES III OF
COURSE.
THIS IS A PHENOMENAL MOMENT.
THIS IS REALLY EXTRAORDINARY.
IT JUST SPEAKS TO WHAT HE -- YOU
KNOW, WHAT ANY PERSON WAITING
THIS LONG FOR THIS POSITION --
HIS MOTHER WAS SO REVERED.
EVERYONE LOVED HER.
HE KNEW THAT.
AND HE WOULD BE SO WORRIED ABOUT
STEPPING INTO HER SHOES AND THIS
IS REAINSUSSURANCE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO GIVE HIM A CHANCE.
>> THIS HAS TO, IT DOESN'T MAKE
UP FOR THE LOSS OF HIS MOTHER,
BUT IT HAS TO SOME WAY HELP IN
THE GRIEF TO KNOW THAT, YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE ARE -- PEOPLE LOVED
HIS MOTHER.
AND THEY'RE ALSO SHOWING SUPPORT
FOR HIM AND LOVE AS MAX SAID.
JUST GOT A KISS ON THE LIPS.
NOT SURE HE WAS --
>> HE SMILED.
AND HE DIDN'T FEEL AWKWARD ABOUT
THAT.
HE'S APPROACHED -- HE'S NOT --
WHEN YOU MEET HIM, HE'S A VERY
WARM GUY, BUT, YOU KNOW, NOT
SOMEONE YOU KISS ON THE LIPS.
THAT WAS AN OUTPOURING OF
EXPRESSION BY SOMEONE AND HE
ACCEPTED IT WITHOUT FEELING
AWKWARD.
I THINK THAT WAS A GREAT LIMIT
MOMENT, ACTUALLY.
>> YOU ASKED WHAT IT IS LIKE TO
BE HERE, I MEAN, I WOULD HAVE TO
HONESTLY LIKEN IT TO A CONCERT.
I KNOW WE'RE HERE TO HONOR THE
FORMER QUEEN, BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE CROWD IS EXCITED TO BE HERE.
AND THERE IS CAMILLA, QUEEN
CONSORT NOW.
BUT THE CROWD IS EXCITED TO BE
HERE.
YES, THEY ARE SAD.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THEY HAVE TO MOVE FORWARD.
THEY HAVE A NEW PRIME MINISTER.
THEY GOT A NEW KING, A NEW QUEEN
CONSORT AND THE SUCCESSION
CHANGES AS MAX HAS BEEN
EDUCATING ALL OF US ON
THROUGHOUT OUR COVERAGE HERE.
BUT, THIS HAS TO, YOU KNOW,
REALLY WARM THE HEARTS OF THE
FOLKS WHO ARE WATCHING, THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ROYAL WATCHERS,
WE LOVE THE ROYALS, AND JUST
LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF FLOWERS
AND MAKESHIFT MEMORIAL THAT HAS
POPPED UP OVER THE LAST DAY OR
SO.
IT IS REALLY HEARTENING TO WATCH
THIS AND TO EXPERIENCE IT, I
SHOULD SAY.
>> A WORD ON CAMILLA, SHE'S
SOMEONE WHO ISN'T NATURALLY
COMFORTABLE IN FRONT OF THE
CAMERAS, SOMEONE THAT DOESN'T
CHOOSE TO GO TO EVERY EVENT.
SHE CHOOSES WHICH ONES SHE GOES
TO.
SHE DIPS IN AND OUT.
THIS IS A MASSIVE MOMENT FOR
HER.
SHE DOESN'T -- SHE DOESN'T SEEK
THE LIMELIGHT.
SHE DOESN'T -- I WOULDN'T SAY
SHE WOULD HAVE AN AMBITION TO
BECOME QUEEN, WHATEVER ANYONE
ELSE SAYS.
SHE IS ALWAYS ABOUT SUPPORTING
CHARLES.
THIS IS, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
WHY --
>> CAN WE LISTEN TO THIS?
THEY'RE DOING A HIP HIP HOORAY.
>> SHE IS THERE ALONGSIDE HIM,
WHICH IS WHY HE'S SO SUPPORTIVE
OF HER AS WELL.
WE HAVE KING AND QUEEN OUTSIDE
THEIR NEW RESIDENCE OF
BUCKINGHAM PALACE, LOOKING AT
THE FLOWERS AND TAKING IN THE
MESSAGES.